anyone who has ever been privileged to
direct a film
also knows that although it can be like
trying to write war and peace in a
bumper car in an amusement park
when you finally get it right there are
not many joys in life that can equal the
feeling i know myself i don't like to
read what something is about before i
see it you know what it means i think
that subtlety and
allowing the audience to discover for
themselves what it is is the most
important thing and i think that if you
get involved in any kind of
problem problem solving in depth on
almost anything it
is surprisingly similar to
problem solving of anything you know if
you can develop
a kind of generalized approach to
problem solving that uh it's surprising
how it helps you
in anything i mean he was challenging me
constantly he gave me as much if not
more than i feel i ever ever could
possibly give him kubrick more than any
other filmmaker
understands the potential of movies to
be anything there are no rules as far as
he's concerned when you go to the
theater and when you see them
you're completely surprised they make
you look at life a different way to make
you look at being human a different way
they touch areas that you don't want
touch sometimes which story do you want
to make into a film you can say a lot of
things about
what it should be you know it should be
an interesting story
to offer possibilities for uh
cinematic uh
beauty in terms of photography and
editing and
in the end the truthful and honest in
dealing with
the thematic material
that doesn't really tell you why you
finally choose them you know it does
become this
very uh into fun like uh you know why do
you find one particular girl attractive
or why did you marry your wife
[Music]
i'm sorry not to be able to be with you
tonight
to receive this great honor
of the d.w griffith award
but i'm in london making eyes wide shut
with tom cruise and nicole kidman
and just about this time i'm probably in
the car on the way to the studio
which as it happens
reminds me of a conversation i had with
steven spielberg
about what was the most difficult and
challenging thing about directing a film
and i believe stephen summed it up about
as profoundly as you can
he thought the most difficult and
challenging thing about directing a film
was getting out of the car
i'm sure you all know the feeling
but at the same time anyone who has ever
been privileged to direct a film
also knows that although it can be like
trying to write war and peace in a
bumper car in an amusement park
when you finally get it right there are
not many joys in life that can equal the
feeling
i never like to
say anything about my films because
i think that um
that
the pleasure that an audience receives
in in
discovering
things for themselves
is
a great deal of what one
uh
likes about good films um i i don't i
know myself i don't like uh
to read what something is about what to
be told
uh before i see it you know what it
means
i think the best uh
thing is when an audience
looks at the film and and and wonders
whether
something that they see is an accident
or whether
the director or writer meant them to
to know it i think that subtlety
and uh allowing the audience to discover
for themselves
what it is is is the most important
thing that's why i've always tried to
avoid interviews
and
and explanations about the films i think
the film
you know should be able to speak for
itself what made him so good
well i think
the one thing you know you go to movies
you go to movies to be
to be involved in the picture uh
to get a sense i just want to i want to
lose myself up on that screen
for a few hours and uh
uh in a sense
notice like to be human
in a way
um then you come across certain kinds of
films
that um
when you go to the theater and when you
see them
you're completely surprised they make
you look at life a different way to make
you look at being human a different way
they touch areas that you don't want
touch sometimes yeah uh it's provoked
provoke you which is good
um and then there's that rarest of films
where when you see it continually
over years
10 15 20 30 40 years
you still see more in it i don't know
there obviously are cultural differences
in reactions to film kurosawa went
absolutely crazy over the pic peter
brooke who i never met sent me a note
from paris
well i mean i don't know what led me to
make any of the films really that i've
made i became interested in them when i
read them or when
i thought about the subject
so i'm now going through the problem of
trying to decide what film to make next
and i realize that my own thought
processes are
very hard to define in terms of uh what
story do you want to make into a film
you can say a lot of things about
what it should be you know it should be
an interesting story
to offer possibilities for uh
cinematic uh
beauty in terms of photography and
editing and
it's in the end truthful and honest in
dealing with uh the thematic material
that doesn't really tell you why you
finally choose them and you know it does
become this uh
very uh in the fun like uh you know why
do you find uh one particular girl
attractive or why did you marry your
wife kubrick more than any
other filmmaker
understands the potential of movies to
be anything he understands that that
screen
that form in which you're watching that
you're sitting with an audience
looking up at that screen
that screen can take you anywhere and do
anything there are no rules as far as
he's concerned
the idea of what
can cinema do that other
art forms can't how can that create
a purely cinematic experience for you
and i think that um
if you uh
get involved in any kind of uh
problem problem solving in depth on
almost anything
it
is surprisingly similar to uh
problem solving of anything you know
i started out by just you know getting a
camera and learning how to take pictures
and learning how to print pictures and
learning how to build a dark room and
learning how to do all the technical
things and
so on and so on and then finally trying
to find out how you could sell pictures
and become a you know it would be
possible to be a professional
photographer and it was a case of over a
period of say from the age of 13 to 17
you might say
going through step by step by myself
without anybody really helping me the
problem solving of being becoming a
photographer and i found that um
i think in looking back that
the uh
this particular thing about problem
solving is something that
uh schools generally don't teach you
and that uh if you can develop uh
a kind of generalized approach to
problem solving
that uh
it's surprising how it helps you
in anything you know and that
most of the most of the uh deficiencies
that you see around you and people that
say are you don't think particularly
you're doing their job right or
something is really that i mean assuming
that they care and you know a lot of
people that appear to care or may
actually care are still not uh going
about things probably the right way
when you think about it i generally find
that it's just that they don't have a
good generalized approach to problem
solving they're not thorough they
don't consider all the possibilities
they don't prepare themselves with the
right information and so forth so i
think that photography
uh though it seemed like a hobby
and but and ultimately led to a
professional job photography
uh
might have been more valuable than uh
you know uh doing the proper things in
school when you say you asked question
before how did he think of himself the
word genius was clearly not allowed not
allowed absolutely someone said stanley
you're a genius oh yeah but
it was almost
came close to insult
because you know bach always said about
himself when he was called a genius that
genius is 10
talent which is the mystery yeah which
we don't know what it is 90 hard work
it's it's about inspiration and
perspiration right yeah hard work yeah
and that's what it was then that was it
was almost like a
he was a hard worker i mean some people
call him obsessive yeah what does it
mean a perfectionist i consider it a
compliment
to be a perfectionist yes he was and he
was very demanding it was very difficult
but so what yeah then i had calculated
that i could make a feature film for
about ten thousand dollars i mean at
this point i was the whole crew
cameraman assistant cameraman uh
you know director uh
everything so i had no cost i
totally failed to recognize the what i
didn't know about making films or
anything you know i just thought well
i got the film made
and uh but it was a very very dull
with the exception of
one or two of the actors they were all
terrible actors and i knew nothing about
directing any actors it uh never never
returned a penny of its investment
again not not one single offer ever to
do anything you know from anybody
so i uh in about two weeks knocked
together another script with somebody
and uh
this time it was sort of a reaction to
the other one uh this was nothing but
action sequences what is it that
interest you most about him
well i think
as a filmmaker
you have to tell a story to the audience
and in so doing you have to translate it
through an image
which means that you direct the eye and
the heart
to look in a certain way the way you
want it to be the way you want them to
see it and i never saw anybody tell a
story that way pretty much every one of
the films pretty much every one of the
films you can study the shots
first of all you don't go study the shot
you go look at the movie and it affects
you it doesn't affect you yeah they
affected me and then i went back when i
began to learn more about filmmaking i
went back and i kept saying why is that
one so powerful why is it so powerful i
look back and i try to trace backwards
the shots and then eventually you know
eventually it was i started making films
before there was video so i had to do
this going from theater to theater you
know so it was a different thing i was
trying to write down notes so it's it's
it be why does something stay
um with you for so many years why do the
tracking shots and pads of glory stay
with you
it's really
a person with a very strong
powerful
storytelling
ability
talent genius
who could create a solid rock image
that has conviction
and that that is the image what's in
that frame stays in that frame what is
it in the frame is out and that's it you
have to compose it in that frame in
getting to know him i understood what
the what the dynamic of the relationship
was
that
stanley would give me advice he'd
collaborate with me i tell him a story i
was interested in directing as a movie
and he'd ask me all the tough questions
what do you find interesting about that
story
why do you want to make that picture
gee that sounds kind of boring to me how
can you make that interesting i mean he
was challenging me constantly he gave me
as much if not more than i feel i ever
ever could possibly give him
first he gave me all his movies and then
he gave me his friendship which meant he
gave me his time
and there's no greater gift a person can
give to another person
you